معنى الالم من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك
يعني اهجمات اوكرانيه في البحر الاسود
واخرى في القرن هل نحن امام
استراتيجيه جديده الان يعني تجريها
نحن الان امام تصعيد وتصعيد مقابل
بدات تصعيد بصوره حقيقيه وجاده في الهجوم
الثاني على جسر القرم والذي تزامن مع
انتهاء اتفاقيه
الحبوب
وبالتالي كان هناك رد روسي
الرد الروسي قبل برد الاوكراني على اهداف
المنطقه وهنا
دخل طرفي صراع في دائره توسيع منطقه
العمليات وفي انتقاء الاهداف وبالتالي اذا
نظرنا الى هذه الاهداف من بعد تحليلي نجد
ان الجانب الاوكراني اجاد استخدام
الطائرات المسيره
والزوارق المسيره تمكن من
اعطاب ناقله نفط
وسفينه انزال وصل الى موسكو هاجم في منطقه
ابراج موسكو بعض المباني التي او المبنى
الذي له علاقه مع وزاره الدفاع ومديريات
وزاره الدفاع ودائره الامن السيبراني
بالمقابل الجانب الروسي بدا يكثف في
استخدام الصواريخ باتجاه اهداف مدقه بداها
بمهاجنه هاجمت الموانع سواء في اوديسيا او
على نهر الدانوب ومن ثم الان انتقل الى
القواعد التي تقع في العمق الغربي فهاجم
ثلاثه قواعد اذا دعيني اقول هناك تباطؤ في
رسم وايقاع العمليات البريه فالان كانوا
البديل توسيع دائره الاهداف باستخدام
الوسائل المتاحه من كلا الجانبين فتم
توسيع دائره الصراع
يعني وقد ذكرت استهداف الاوكرانيين لموسكو
الى اي مدى تستطيع اوكرانيا برايك مواصله
نقل هذه المعركه الى داخل الروسي او
المناطق التي تحتلها روسيا كالقرب على
سبيل المثال وقد استهدفت اليوم اوكرانيا
هذا الجسر البديل هناك
يعني هذا الامر يعتمد على ما هي قدرات
الجانب الاوكراني لانه هناك قدرات لا يمكن
الافصاح عنها وتبقى تحت
ما يسمى بسريه العمليات العسكريه سواء في
البعد التخطيطي او التنفيذي الان
لديها القدره على الوصول الى موسكو الى
قاعده انجلز الى ابراج موسكو وهذا اصبح
عمل شبه يومي ان لم يكن كل 48 ساعه اما
شبيه جزيره القرم فهي تحت التاثير وكانه
هناك توجه لعسكره البحر الاسود لان اليد
العليا والهيمنه روسيه لكن الجانب
الاوكراني يقول لدي الاوراق لالحاق الضرر
في الجانب الروسي واثبت ذلك فعليا طيب
يعني ما دلاله ايضا اعتماد اوكرانيا على
الوحده الفا في تلك في هجماتها تلك ضد
روسيا ما هي طبيعه هذه الوحده وما هي
استخداماتها
يعني الان بغض النظر عن الاسماء والمسميات
الان هناك تنظيم عسكري معتمد اهمها ما
يتعلق بامن الدوله ودخولها على خط
العمليات
وسوائل الان لديها تنظيمات من صلب القوات
الاوكرانيه ولديها تنظيمات الرديفه في
العالمي فيلق موسكو الى غير ذلك وبالتالي
بغض النظر عن هذه الاسماء لكن فرقه الفا
هي فرقه مصممه لتنفيذ العمليات الخاصه
والمحدده التي تحتاج الى مهاره قتاليه
عاليه ولكنها تحتاج الى توظيف استخباري من
اجل ضمان نجاح العمليه شكرا لك اللواء
فايز دويريه الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
كنت معنا من عمان